Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. It is but seldom in actual life that the tragic and dramatic notes of action and feeling are struck with the force and frequency with which they were sounded in the Tichborne case. This strange episode, indeed, may be regarded as having been a species of moral tornado, which sweeping suddenly into the social midst, swept men from their feet. In its rushing and conflicting currents were excited every sort of human passion. Prejudice, justice, anger, bitterness, heroic disinterestedness, sordid cupidity, ambition, devotion, cowardice, courage.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。在现实生活中，像蒂奇伯恩案（Tichborne case）中那样，以如此强烈的力度和频率奏响行动与情感的悲剧和戏剧音符，实属罕见。事实上，这一离奇的插曲可以被视为一场道德龙卷风，它突然席卷了社会中心，让人们站立不稳。在其汹涌而冲突的潮流中，各种人类情感都被激发了出来。偏见、正义、愤怒、苦涩、英雄般的无私、卑劣的贪婪、野心、奉献、怯懦、勇气。
In a word, every man's strength or weakness, the whole gamut of human motive and emotion raging and swirling about one large, melancholy, monstrous, mysterious figure. So, Tom, those were the words of Arabe arabella canely who was a eugenicist a novelist and anti-feminist she was also the daughter of an eccentric irish barrister called edward canely and she is talking about the titchborne case yeah the greatest trial of victorian england arguably the most exciting and dramatic trial in all British history, which forms the centrepiece, as do those words, of Zadie Smith's brilliant novel, The Fraud, which you've been reading. Now, you don't normally read fiction, Tom, it's fair to say,
总之，每个人的长处或短处，人类动机和情感的全部光谱，都在一个庞大、忧郁、怪诞、神秘的人物周围狂暴地旋转。那么，汤姆，这些话出自阿拉贝拉·卡内利（Arabella Kenealy），她是一位优生学家、小说家和反女权主义者，也是一位名叫爱德华·卡内利（Edward Kenealy）的古怪爱尔兰大律师的女儿。她谈论的正是蒂奇伯恩案，是的，这是维多利亚时代英国最伟大的审判，可以说是英国历史上最令人兴奋和戏剧性的审判，它构成了扎迪·史密斯（Zadie Smith）精彩小说《欺诈》（The Fraud）的核心，正如这些话一样，你一直在读这本书。汤姆，你通常不读小说，这很公平，
because you don't like books that are imaginative. Is that the case? I do make exceptions for our greatest living novelists, Dominic. People that you meet at dinner parties. Is that not the case? That's what you said to me? No, not at all. I did happen to meet Zadie at a party. Of course. And she did mention that she had been writing a book on the Tichborne claimant, and my ears immediately pricked up. Because as you say, this is an absolutely incredible story. I mean, it has curses, it has disputed inheritances, it has mad attempts to pass off various identities, and it's a case that obsesses Victorian Britain for years and years and years. So the moment the fraud came out,
因为你不喜欢充满想象力的书。是这样吗？多米尼克，我确实会为我们最伟大的在世小说家破例。你在晚宴上遇到的人。不是这样吗？你就是这么跟我说的？不，完全不是。我确实在一次聚会上碰巧遇到了扎迪。当然。她确实提到她一直在写一本关于蒂奇伯恩冒名顶替者的书，我的耳朵立刻竖了起来。因为正如你所说，这是一个绝对不可思议的故事。我的意思是，它有诅咒，有遗产纠纷，有冒充各种身份的疯狂尝试，这是一个让维多利亚时代的英国痴迷了多年又多年的案件。所以《欺诈》一出版，
I did indeed rush out and read it. I thought you were going to say, I did rush out and suck up to the author, but no, you read the book. She doesn't need my praise. I mean, she's the most garlanded novelist of modern Britain. But what I will say is that it weaves in the facts of this extraordinary case with all kinds of meditations on fiction, on race, on empire, on all kinds of things. But it brilliantly articulates why this case obsessed people. So I'm just going to read a very short passage. So this is about a servant girl in the household of the novelist William Harrison Ainsworth. I think he's the guy who basically invents the legend of Dick Turpin. I mean, he was a very, very prolific Victorian novelist who no one reads now.
我就真的冲去读了。我以为你会说，我冲去拍作者的马屁了，但没有，你读了这本书。她不需要我的赞美。我的意思是，她是现代英国获奖最多的小说家。但我要说的是，它将这个非凡案件的事实与对小说、种族、帝国以及各种事物的沉思交织在一起。但它精彩地阐述了为什么这个案件让人们如此着迷。所以我打算读一小段。这是关于小说家威廉·哈里森·安斯沃思（William Harrison Ainsworth）家里的一个女仆。我想他就是那个基本上发明了迪克·特平（Dick Turpin）传说的人。我的意思是，他是一位非常多产的维多利亚时代小说家，现在没人读他的书了。
Anyway, so this is a servant girl in his household who ends up marrying him. And she becomes obsessed by the story of the Tichborne claimant. So no story captured her quite like the saga of the Tichborne claimant. It had everything, toffs, Catholics, money, sex, mistaken identity and inheritance, high court judges, snobbery, exotic locations, the struggle of the honest working man as opposed to the undeserving poor and the power of a mother's love. So dramatic stuff, Dominic. And we thought, I mean, an ideal subject for The Rest is History.
总之，这是他家里的一个女仆，后来嫁给了他。她开始痴迷于蒂奇伯恩冒名顶替者的故事。所以没有哪个故事像蒂奇伯恩冒名顶替者的传奇那样吸引她。它应有尽有：贵族、天主教徒、金钱、性、身份错认和遗产、高等法院法官、势利、异国情调、诚实劳动者与不配得穷人的斗争，以及母爱的力量。真是戏剧性十足，多米尼克。我们想，我的意思是，这是《历史的余味》的理想主题。
And who better to talk about it than Zadie Smith herself. Hello. Who joins us. Hiya. Thanks for having me. Welcome to The Rest is History, and who better to talk about it than Zadie Smith herself. Hello. Who joins us. Hiya. Thanks for having me. Welcome to The Rest Is History, Zadie. Thank you. That's a characteristically long build-up. Normally when you go on a podcast, I imagine people introduce you, bring you on immediately.
还有谁比扎迪·史密斯本人更适合谈论它呢？你好。欢迎加入我们。嗨。谢谢你们邀请我。欢迎来到《历史的余味》，扎迪。谢谢。这真是一个典型的漫长铺垫。通常当你参加播客时，我想人们会介绍你，然后立刻让你上场。
No, it's nice. But we like to keep people waiting. We like to increase the tension. It's good. It's good. Well, it's like a Victorian novel. Yeah. Yeah. Big intro. Thank you. All right. So the Titchbourne case. So for people who don't know anything about it, which I'm guessing is the vast majority of people, in very, very broad terms to start with, explain what it is and maybe what drew you to it. I've been doing a few readings and my experience
不，这很好。但我们喜欢让人们等待。我们喜欢增加紧张感。这很好。这很好。嗯，这就像一部维多利亚时代的小说。是的。是的。宏大的开场。谢谢。好吧。那么蒂奇伯恩案。对于那些对此一无所知的人，我猜是绝大多数人，首先用非常非常宽泛的术语解释一下它是什么，以及是什么吸引了你。我做了一些阅读，我的经验是
is when you start trying to explain the case, then the event is over. By the time I get to the end of the trial, there's no time for the event, but I try and do it as quickly as possible. So a Catholic aristocrat, a young man called Sir Roger Tichborne, he was going to Jamaica. He was going on his kind of year off adventure. The boat went down with everybody on board. Everybody died. But his mother, who was French and hated the family she'd married into, decided that he was still alive and put adverts all around England and then all around Europe and finally all around Australia, offering larger and larger amounts of money for the return of her son, which seems unwise and like a temptation to fraudsters.
当你开始试图解释这个案件时，事件就已经结束了。等我讲到审判结束时，已经没有时间讲事件本身了，但我会尽量快点讲。所以，一位天主教贵族，一个叫罗杰·蒂奇伯恩（Sir Roger Tichborne）的年轻人，他要去牙买加。他要去进行那种间隔年的冒险。船沉了，船上所有人都在。所有人都死了。但他那法国籍的母亲，讨厌她嫁入的那个家庭，认定他还活着，并在全英国，然后是全欧洲，最后是全世界，包括澳大利亚，到处张贴广告，为找回她的儿子提供越来越多的钱，这看起来很不理智，就像是对骗子的诱惑。
And about 20 years later, a man does turn up with a black Jamaican with him who was a servant of the Titchbourne family. And together they arrive in Paris, where Roger's mother was, and say, well, I'm your son. And the problem with it was that their son was tall and thin. This man, who was called Arthur Autumn, was about 300 pounds. He's a large man very large man the son was uh educated grew up speaking french arthur orton did not speak french was not educated was a butcher from whopping had a thick cockney accent um despite
大约20年后，一个男人带着一个牙买加黑人出现了，那个人是蒂奇伯恩家的仆人。他们一起到达了罗杰母亲所在的巴黎，说，好吧，我是你的儿子。问题在于，他们的儿子又高又瘦。这个名叫亚瑟·奥顿（Arthur Orton）的男人大约有300磅重。他是个大块头，非常大的大块头。儿子受过教育，从小讲法语，亚瑟·奥顿不会讲法语，没受过教育，是个来自沃平（Wapping）的屠夫，有浓重的伦敦腔，嗯，尽管
all of this the mother said that's my son for reasons maybe of perversity or of genuine longing. Anyway, she said it, gave him £1,000 a year and then promptly died. And that was the problem, starting an enormous court case because Sir Roger Tichborne was owed this enormous estate in Hampshire, but also like a substantial part of central London. All that bit around Tottenham Court road doughty street it was big they'd married into the doughty family yeah which had brought the titchborns all this extra money and land it was a double clan a lot of land a lot of money and so it started a court case that lasted
所有这些，母亲还是说那是我的儿子，原因可能是出于反常，也可能是出于真切的渴望。总之，她说了，给了他每年1000英镑，然后很快就去世了。这就是问题所在，引发了一场巨大的法庭诉讼，因为罗杰·蒂奇伯恩爵士在汉普郡拥有这笔巨大的遗产，而且在伦敦市中心也拥有相当大的一部分。托特纳姆法院路（Tottenham Court Road）和道蒂街（Doughty Street）周围的那一片，很大，他们嫁入了道蒂家族，是的，这给蒂奇伯恩家带来了所有这些额外的金钱和土地，这是一个双重家族，大量的土地，大量的金钱，所以它引发了一场持续了
for a year and a bit at which point he was found to be lying so then there was a criminal case after that so altogether it's about two and a half years in court yeah yeah so this is in the 1860s and 1870s isn't it so it's reported in gazettes and in kind of scandal sheets the amazing thing about it is it captures the public imagination as much as it does because from the way you described it it sounds like a kind of bizarre victorian case that would you know proceed in the courts and ultimately who cares right but actually it's that reading that Tom just did earlier suggests it's something that it had all these issues because it had London Australia he'd got shipwrecked in South America hadn't he right first hadn't he been going to Valparaiso in Chile yeah
一年多的法庭诉讼，在那一点上他被发现撒谎了，所以在那之后又有一场刑事诉讼，所以总共在法庭上待了大约两年半，是的，是的，所以这是在1860年代和1870年代，对吧？所以它在公报和那种丑闻小报上被报道，关于它最神奇的事情是它捕捉到了公众的想象力，因为它就像你描述的那样，听起来像是一种奇怪的维多利亚时代案件，你知道会在法庭上进行，最终谁在乎呢，对吧？但实际上，汤姆刚才读的那段话表明，它之所以有所有这些问题，是因为它涉及伦敦、澳大利亚，他在南美洲遭遇了海难，不是吗？对，他不是要去智利的瓦尔帕莱索吗？是的。
and race obviously because as you said there's the black guy who's with him who's an old servant of the family is that right Andrew Bogle yeah and giving testimony every day in court I mean that was quite a sight I thought after I finished it I kind of dawned on me that when you have a Jamaican an Irish lawyer from Cork who's very eccentric and a working class Englishman you're basically dramatizing in the center of English power, the whole problem of the 19th century, which is, oh God, the Jamaicans, oh God, the Irish, and oh God, the working classes. These are three things that people are really wanting to think about. And suddenly they're being dramatized daily in the Queen's Court. It didn't really occur to me when I was writing it, but when you step back,
还有种族问题，显然，因为正如你所说，和他在一起的那个黑人是这个家庭的老仆人，是吗？安德鲁·博格尔（Andrew Bogle），是的，每天在法庭上作证。我的意思是，那真是一番景象。我想在我读完之后，我意识到当你有一个牙买加人、一个来自科克的非常古怪的爱尔兰律师和一个工人阶级的英国人时，你基本上是在英国权力的中心上演19世纪的整个问题，那就是，哦天哪，牙买加人，哦天哪，爱尔兰人，哦天哪，工人阶级。这是人们真正想思考的三件事。突然间，它们每天都在女王的法庭上被戏剧化。我在写的时候并没有真正意识到这一点，但当你退后一步，
you can see the obsession. But also that sense of people from different classes and different backgrounds being brought together is very reminiscent of Dickens, who appears as a figure in your novel. Those kind of great portmanteau Victorian novels, there is a quality of this whole case about that. No court case in a Victorian novel is worth anything without an ancestral curse. And what's even better is that the Tichborne claimant features an ancestral curse that supposedly goes back to the 12th century. And I wonder, before we get into the absolute details of the case itself, could we go back to the story of the Tichborne Dole and the curse that visits
你可以看到这种痴迷。而且那种来自不同阶级和背景的人被聚集在一起的感觉，非常让人想起狄更斯，他作为你小说中的一个人物出现。那些伟大的维多利亚时代大部头小说，整个案件都有这种特质。维多利亚时代的小说中，没有哪个法庭案件没有祖传诅咒是不值一提的。更棒的是，蒂奇伯恩冒名顶替者案件中有一个据称可以追溯到12世纪的祖传诅咒。我想，在我们进入案件本身的绝对细节之前，我们能不能回到蒂奇伯恩施舍（Tichborne Dole）的故事，以及那个降临在
itself upon the Tichborne family? I the curse that visits itself upon the Tichborne family. I find this part of the story really disturbing because I like to think of myself as a rational actor interested in rational things. But this story, it is a curse and it does come true. So there is a previous Sir Roger Tichborne, hundreds of years earlier, who has a sick wife, Lady Mabella. And as she's dying, she has this concern about the poor in hampshire and she says she wants something to be kept for them so she decides i don't understand the logic of this really but she decides to crawl around the land to crawl to crawl well she's very ill isn't she she's ill she doesn't have an option dominic's what i'm saying she can't walk so she crawls no one would carry her no apparently not it's a poor show it's so weird
蒂奇伯恩家族身上的诅咒？我发现故事的这一部分真的很令人不安，因为我喜欢认为自己是一个对理性事物感兴趣的理性行动者。但这个故事，它是一个诅咒，而且它确实成真了。所以，几百年前有一位前任罗杰·蒂奇伯恩爵士，他有一位生病的妻子，玛贝拉夫人（Lady Mabella）。当她快要死的时候，她对汉普郡的穷人很关心，她说她想为他们保留一些东西，所以她决定——我不明白这其中的逻辑——她决定在土地上爬行，去爬行，爬行，好吧，她病得很重，不是吗？她病了，她没有选择，多米尼克，我是在说她不能走路，所以她爬行，没有人会背她，显然没有，这表现很差，太奇怪了
but it's a bet on her deathbed she bets that as far as she can crawl with this lit candle around the land and enclosed it symbolically that amount of land will be given every year whatever grows on that land will be given every year to the poor so she manages 23 acres which on your deathbed it's not bad even on a good day i'm not walking 23 acres well crawling and certainly not on my hands and knees tom you'd do that you'd absolutely do that wouldn't you just for spite i would three stinging nettles and everything yeah if it was for the good of the poor dominic i would do it right to spite your husband so she does it and the promise is made and she said if you don't do that after i'm dead if you
但这是在她临终前的一个赌注，她打赌只要她能带着这支点燃的蜡烛在土地上爬行，并象征性地圈起那块土地，那块土地每年产出的任何东西都会给穷人。所以她爬了23英亩，在临终时，这已经不错了，即使在好日子里，我也不会爬23英亩，更不用说在手和膝盖上爬了，汤姆，你会那样做的，你绝对会那样做，不是吗？只是为了赌气，我会的，三根荨麻什么的，是的，如果这是为了穷人的利益，多米尼克，我会做的，就为了气你丈夫，所以她做了，承诺也做出了，她说如果你在我死后不这样做，如果你
don't give the profit from this land to these poor people, there will be a curse on you. There will be seven brothers born and then seven sisters, and then the family will fall into ruin. That was the curse. Quite dramatic. It's always seven, isn't it? Always seven.
不把这块土地的利润给这些穷人，你就会受到诅咒。会有七个兄弟出生，然后是七个姐妹，然后这个家族就会陷入毁灭。这就是诅咒。非常戏剧性。总是七，不是吗？总是七。
It's always seven. And they did do the dole for a long time, giving this profit every year, giving the corn. But then it got a little bit wild like so many poor people were turning up that the family disliked the amount of charity they were having to give so they shut it down it's amazing and when they shut it down um the curse begins to come into effect oh oh we love a curse yeah it is pretty wild so sir henry tichborne who's roger's uncle did have i think it's seven daughters there was one son who died so roger tichborne, who's Roger's uncle, did have, I think it's seven daughters.
总是七。他们确实做了很长时间的施舍，每年都把利润给出去，把谷物给出去。但后来它变得有点疯狂，因为太多的穷人出现了，家族不喜欢他们不得不给出的慈善金额，所以他们关闭了它，这太神奇了，当他们关闭它时，嗯，诅咒开始生效了，哦，我们喜欢诅咒，是的，这确实很疯狂，所以亨利·蒂奇伯恩爵士（Sir Henry Tichborne），也就是罗杰的叔叔，确实有，我想是七个女儿，有一个儿子死了，所以罗杰·蒂奇伯恩，也就是罗杰的叔叔，确实有，我想是七个女儿。
There was one son who died. So Roger Tichborne ends up being the only proper descendant. And then, of course, this drama and the family falls into ruin. So Sir Henry Tichborne, that's 1803. He's captured by the French and he's held as a prisoner in the Napoleonic Wars. And it's a very complicated series of marriages and stuff like that. Right. And we end up with a guy called James, who's his son, I think.
有一个儿子死了。所以罗杰·蒂奇伯恩最终成了唯一的正统后裔。然后，当然，这出戏上演了，家族陷入了毁灭。所以亨利·蒂奇伯恩爵士，那是1803年。他被法国人俘虏，在拿破仑战争中被关押。这是一系列非常复杂的婚姻之类的。对。我们最终得到了一个叫詹姆斯的人，我想是他的儿子。
Is that right? Yes. This is so like a Victorian novel. I know. Where's the family tree? Yeah, carry on. Who's married to a French woman descended from the Duke of Bourbon called Henriette. Is that right?
是这样吗？是的。这太像维多利亚时代的小说了。我知道。家谱在哪里？是的，继续。谁娶了一个波旁公爵（Duke of Bourbon）的后裔，名叫亨丽埃特（Henriette）的法国女人。是这样吗？
Yes. And Roger Tichborne is their son. That's it. And he ends up becoming the heir to the entire estate, Roger Tichborne. Yes. And he, I mean, I'm looking at a photo of him. He looks quite dashing, posh. Yeah, he looks dashing.
是的。罗杰·蒂奇伯恩是他们的儿子。就是这样。他最终成为了整个庄园的继承人，罗杰·蒂奇伯恩。是的。而且，我的意思是，我正在看一张他的照片。他看起来相当潇洒，时髦。是的，他看起来很潇洒。
He looks like he'd be played by a young David Niven. He was dashing. Is it fair to say he was not brilliant? He was a bit of a disappointment to them, I think. He was kind of sporty, but violent, not particularly academic in school. Oh, he was violent? Yeah, he was always kind of wandering around with a gun. He played the tuba, apparently, really badly. That's not violent, I don't think. No. Well, the servants would complain it was a violent noise. But he was a unimpressive type i think but his mother absolutely adored him and there was no expectation
他看起来就像会被年轻的大卫·尼文（David Niven）扮演。他很潇洒。公平地说，他并不聪明吗？我想他让他们有点失望。他有点喜欢运动，但很暴力，在学校里学习不是特别好。哦，他很暴力？是的，他总是带着枪到处走。他吹大号，显然，吹得很烂。那不叫暴力，我不觉得。不。嗯，仆人们会抱怨那是一种暴力的噪音。但我认为他是一个平庸的人，但他母亲绝对宠爱他，而且没有期望
of him becoming the heir because there were all these other children but they kept on being girls and then the one boy died yeah so suddenly it was him yeah so 1853 he goes off to south america basically you said on his gap year. Yeah. So he's how old then? He's in his early 20s, is he? Early 20s. Having had a kind of unimpressive school career and military career in Ireland.
他成为继承人，因为还有所有这些其他的孩子，但他们不断地生女孩，然后那个男孩死了，是的，所以突然间就是他了，是的，所以1853年他去了南美洲，基本上你说是在他的间隔年。是的。那么他那时多大？他20出头，是吗？20出头。在爱尔兰有过一段平庸的学校生涯和军事生涯。
Yeah. But weirdly, before he goes, he leaves some sealed letters behind. Oh, God, yeah. It's like a... And no one knows what's in them. It's like a telly novella. Yes, he leaves some sealed letters
是的。但奇怪的是，在他走之前，他留下了一些密封的信件。哦，天哪，是的。这就像一个……而且没人知道里面是什么。这就像一部电视连续剧。是的，他留下了一些密封的信件
buried somewhere in the grounds of Tichborne House. As you do. I always do that when I go away. As you do. Are these ever found? I miss this. So are they still there waiting with a terrible secret or something? No, they were found and destroyed.
埋在蒂奇伯恩宅邸的土地里的某个地方。就像你做的那样。我离开时总是那样做。就像你做的那样。这些被找到了吗？我错过了这个。所以它们还在那里等着什么可怕的秘密吗？不，它们被找到了并销毁了。
So that allowed it to be, you know, this kind of black box in the middle of a trial. What was in them? Because was it not later said? Yes. That there was a sex scandal. There is a sex scandal. That was to do with the letters. But actually, then other people said the letters were all about the disposal of fields and stuff like that.
所以这让它成为，你知道，审判中间的那个黑匣子。里面是什么？因为后来不是有人说吗？是的。有一个性丑闻。有一个性丑闻。那和信件有关。但实际上，其他人说信件全是关于田地处置之类的东西。
I don't think there was any sex, but it blew up the trial. So in the middle of it, when he's still trying to prove that he is Sir Roger Tichborne, he's asked, if you are Sir Roger Tichborne, you'd know what was in those sealed letters. And he spontaneously makes up this incredible story that he had impregnated his cousin. It was instructions as to how to deal with the pregnancy. Can you imagine? You've got to go big with something like that, haven't you?
我不认为有什么性丑闻，但它炸毁了审判。所以在审判中间，当他还在试图证明他是罗杰·蒂奇伯恩爵士时，有人问他，如果你是罗杰·蒂奇伯恩爵士，你应该知道那些密封信件里写了什么。他自发地编造了一个不可思议的故事，说他让他的表妹怀孕了。那是关于如何处理怀孕的说明。你能想象吗？你得用那种事情搞大点，不是吗？
Yeah. But that's what's so amazing about Arthur Orton is that he's got that Trumpian instinct of... Lie big. The bigger the lie, the better. Yeah. Just if you're going to lie, go all the way... Lie big. The bigger the lie, the better. Yeah. Just if you're going to lie, go all the way. All right, but let's just stick with Roger.
是的。但这就是亚瑟·奥顿最神奇的地方，他有那种特朗普式的本能……撒大谎。谎言越大，效果越好。是的。如果你要撒谎，就彻底地……撒大谎。谎言越大，效果越好。是的。如果你要撒谎，就彻底地。好吧，但让我们坚持讲罗杰。
Yeah. Sorry, Roger's in South America. Yes. So he's a kind of tuba playing Bertie Worcester. Yeah, that's fair. But more violent, but more into Zadie. Yeah, a little more violent. A violent tuba playing Bertie Worcester.
是的。抱歉，罗杰在南美洲。是的。所以他是一个吹大号的伯蒂·伍斯特（Bertie Wooster）。是的，这很公平。但更暴力，但更喜欢扎迪。是的，稍微暴力一点。一个吹大号的暴力伯蒂·伍斯特。
Yeah. Okay. He's been messing around in kind of Buenos Aires and stuff. Yeah. And then he's going to Jamaica and his ship capsizes. Is that right? Yeah. It's wrecked orester. Yeah. Okay. He's been messing around in kind of Buenos Aires and stuff. And then he's going to Jamaica and his ship capsizes. Is that right? Yeah. It's wrecked or whatever.
是的。好吧。他在布宜诺斯艾利斯之类的地方鬼混。是的。然后他要去牙买加，他的船翻了。是这样吗？是的。它失事了，或者别的什么。
Yeah. And that's the end of him. Or is it? But his mother, because she's French, Tom, she doesn't give up. Well, she's also Victorian. French and Victorian. It's practically inexcusable. She consults Clairvoyance, doesn't she?
是的。那就是他的结局。或者不是？但他母亲，因为她是法国人，汤姆，她没有放弃。嗯，她也是维多利亚时代的。法国人和维多利亚时代的。这简直不可原谅。她咨询了千里眼，不是吗？
And the Clairvoyance say, listen, he's alive. He's out there. Yeah. And she completely believes it. She believes it. And everybody in the family tries to stop her doing this, but she's completely obsessed. And the adverts, when they reach Australia, they're also given to kind of agents who actively help look for missing people.
千里眼说，听着，他还活着。他在外面。是的。她完全相信了。她相信了。家里每个人都试图阻止她这样做，但她完全着迷了。而且那些广告，当它们到达澳大利亚时，也给了那些积极寻找失踪人口的代理人。
And that is also a slightly distorted business. So you're paying someone to actively find someone hundreds of thousands of miles away. The whole system is ripe for manipulation, I'd say. And so while this is going on, while her agents are out looking for her son in the hope that he's not drowned, who is laying claim to the Tichborne estate? It's about to go to a baby son who has been born. There's one more child. Right. Previously to that, his uncle Henry is in the house, I think. He has it for the moment, waiting for a child of his to take it over. But by the time Arthur Orton comes back,
这也是一个稍微扭曲的生意。所以你付钱给某人去积极寻找几十万英里外的人。整个系统都成熟到可以被操纵，我会说。所以当这一切发生时，当她的代理人在外面寻找她的儿子，希望他没有淹死时，谁在对蒂奇伯恩庄园提出要求？它即将传给一个刚出生的男婴。还有一个孩子。对。在此之前，他的叔叔亨利在房子里，我想。他暂时拥有它，等着他的孩子来接管。但当亚瑟·奥顿回来时，
there's a tenant in there, Mr. Lushington, who is just renting the place because the Tichbornes at that point are not as rich as they once were. So it's Lushington who gets chucked out for this whopping butcher. But are there people, I mean, Titchborns or relatives of Titchborns or whatever, who stand massively to gain if Sir Roger is indeed proven to be drowned or lose out if he is proved to be alive? Yes, his uncle is the one who would gain most. Right. And anybody who comes from his uncle's line. I mean, it is still an enormous amount of land. So yeah, he has to be dead as far as they're concerned. But I think even more of their worry is that this unknown butcher is going
里面有一个租户，拉辛顿先生（Mr. Lushington），他只是租了这个地方，因为蒂奇伯恩家当时不像以前那么富有了。所以是拉辛顿被赶出去给这个沃平的屠夫腾地方。但有没有人，我的意思是，蒂奇伯恩家的人或蒂奇伯恩家的亲戚什么的，如果罗杰爵士确实被证明淹死了，他们会获得巨大的利益，或者如果他被证明还活着，他们会损失惨重？是的，他的叔叔是获益最大的人。对。以及任何来自他叔叔那一脉的人。我的意思是，这仍然是一大片土地。所以是的，就他们而言，他必须死。但我认为他们更担心的是这个不知名的屠夫要
to take over everything they have. That is the motivation. So let's look at the butcher then. Yes. So how is it that he appears on the scene i think coincidence plays an incredible role like when you look at the photo that was published in all the newspapers of him and sir roger of course there's 300 pounds between them but i have to say the eyes are similar oh it's edgy dense the eyes are similar it was enough they're different man i mean i'm just i know they're different men but can you see, I mean, the photos, even I began to convince myself at a certain point, but the eyes are a bit similar.
接管他们拥有的一切。这就是动机。那么让我们看看那个屠夫。是的。他是怎么出现在现场的？我认为巧合起到了不可思议的作用，就像当你看到所有报纸上刊登的他和罗杰爵士的照片时，当然他们之间有300磅的差距，但我必须说眼睛很像，哦，它很边缘，眼睛很像，这就足够了，他们是不同的人，我的意思是，我只是，我知道他们是不同的人，但你能看出来吗，我的意思是，照片，甚至我在某个时刻也开始说服自己，但眼睛有点像。
And at some point, somehow, in Sydney, he came across Andrew Bogle. So Andrew Bogle had this long, incredible life of being an enslaved man in Jamaica, then plucked off the plantation by Sir Henry to be a page for him for 20 years, then released by the family. He'd married a white English woman, had a couple of kids. She died. Then he married another English woman and they moved to Australia. And he was living in Sydney with these children. His wife had died again. He was alone. And somehow he came across Sir Roger. Sir Roger being the butcher. Yeah, the butcher. He says he recognised him.
在某个时刻，不知何故，在悉尼，他遇到了安德鲁·博格尔。所以安德鲁·博格尔有着漫长、不可思议的一生，他曾是牙买加的奴隶，然后被亨利爵士从种植园里带走，做了20年的侍从，然后被家族释放。他娶了一个英国白人妇女，生了几个孩子。她死了。然后他又娶了另一个英国妇女，他们搬到了澳大利亚。他带着这些孩子住在悉尼。他的妻子又去世了。他孤身一人。不知何故，他遇到了罗杰爵士。罗杰爵士就是那个屠夫。是的，那个屠夫。他说他认出了他。
It seems impossible to me. So I've got a question about all that. Yeah. You were saying about the people who do the finding? Yeah. So 11 years have passed. We're now in 1865, since 1854 when Roger was lost. And there's a bloke who, in a splendidly Australian thing,
这对我来说似乎是不可能的。所以我有一个关于所有这些的问题。是的。你刚才说关于那些寻找的人？是的。所以11年过去了。我们现在是1865年，自1854年罗杰失踪以来。有一个家伙，以一种非常澳大利亚的方式，
he's from Wagga Wagga. And this bloke from Wagga Wagga pitches up and says, I think you're Roger Tichborne. That's it. William Gibbs, I think his name is. The Wagga Wagga man. Yeah. Is the Wagga Wagga man really the architect of all this?
他来自瓦加瓦加（Wagga Wagga）。这个来自瓦加瓦加的家伙跑过来说，我想你是罗杰·蒂奇伯恩。就是这样。威廉·吉布斯（William Gibbs），我想他叫这个名字。那个瓦加瓦加人。是的。那个瓦加瓦加人真的是这一切的策划者吗？
So basically he's doing it for money. He's found a bloke that looks like Tichborne. He finds the servant and he says, I'll put the two together. It's in everyone's interests that you recognize each other. That's it. It's put together. And the gardener, weirdly, of the Titchborns is also out there, a man called Guilfoyle, also in Sydney. So I think it's put together. I like to think that Bogle maybe at some point was sincerely convinced of this. But the moment he says he recognizes Sir Roger, the Titchborn family, who up to that point had given him a £50 a year
所以基本上他是为了钱。他找到了一个看起来像蒂奇伯恩的家伙。他找到了那个仆人，他说，我会把这两个人凑在一起。你们互相认出来对大家都有好处。就是这样。它是被凑在一起的。而且奇怪的是，蒂奇伯恩家的园丁也在那里，一个叫吉尔福伊尔（Guilfoyle）的人，也在悉尼。所以我认为它是被凑在一起的。我喜欢认为博格尔也许在某个时刻真诚地相信了这一点。但当他说他认出了罗杰爵士时，蒂奇伯恩家族，他们在那之前一直给他每年50英镑的
annuity, stop it immediately. So that fact is very interesting that he lost everything he had, his only means of support by supporting this claim. So I think the English public took that either as an example of his complete sincerity, like you're willing to lose everything to support this man. Or of course, the other argument is you're in for a penny hoping for a pound, right? So you give up 50 pounds hoping for a much bigger win further down the line. You say in the novel that whatever side of the thing a person was on, admiration for Bogle appeared universal. So when they go back, he is seen as a figure of the utmost moral quality. Because I think either he's sincere or he's extremely canny. And in both cases
年金，立刻停止了。所以那个事实非常有趣，他失去了他拥有的一切，他唯一的支持手段，通过支持这个主张。所以我认为英国公众要么把它看作他完全真诚的例子，就像你愿意失去一切来支持这个人。或者当然，另一个论点是你为了赚大钱而投入一点点，对吧？所以你放弃50英镑，希望在未来获得更大的胜利。你在小说中说，无论一个人站在哪一边，对博格尔的钦佩似乎是普遍的。所以当他们回去时，他被视为一个具有最高道德品质的人物。因为我认为要么他是真诚的，要么他是极其精明的。而在两种情况下
that's a reason for admiration in terms of the working classes watching this case and which do you think he is you can't ask a novelist that i think it's possible for people to convince themselves of anything yeah i think it's a mixture of both yeah there's a story by borges where he implies that bogle is just an incredible fiction writer, basically, and he's there for a kind of personal reparations, which makes perfect sense. How better to get your just desserts out of the English government than messing with their court system for two years and then taking the reward? I mean, that does make sense. Your description of him, I thought he sounds like Morgan Freeman. In the adaptation of the novel, he'd be played by Morgan Freeman.
这都是钦佩的原因，就观看这个案件的工人阶级而言，你认为他是哪一种？你不能问小说家这个问题，我认为人们有可能说服自己相信任何事情，是的，我认为两者兼而有之，是的，博尔赫斯（Borges）有一个故事，他暗示博格尔只是一个不可思议的小说家，基本上，他在那里是为了某种个人赔偿，这完全说得通。还有什么比折腾英国司法系统两年然后拿走奖励更能从英国政府那里得到你应得的报应呢？我的意思是，这确实说得通。你对他的描述，我觉得他听起来像摩根·弗里曼（Morgan Freeman）。在小说的改编版中，他会被摩根·弗里曼扮演。
I went and looked up a photo of him and he does look a bit like Morgan Freeman. In the adaptation of the novel, he'd be played by Morgan Freeman. I went and looked up a photo of him and he does look a bit like Morgan Freeman. He does. He had this kind of innate nobility in the trial transcripts where everybody else is really behaving so badly. The lawyers are ridiculous. The witnesses are ridiculous. The whole behavior of the courtroom is absurd. He just is this calm centre. He seems to speak the truth. He's sometimes witty. He's sometimes painful to listen to. He's confessional. But he seems sane, where everybody else seems somewhat out of their minds.
我去查了他的照片，他确实看起来有点像摩根·弗里曼。在小说的改编版中，他会被摩根·弗里曼扮演。我去查了他的照片，他确实看起来有点像摩根·弗里曼。他确实。他在审判记录中有一种天生的贵族气质，而其他所有人的表现都太糟糕了。律师们很荒谬。证人们很荒谬。整个法庭的行为都很荒唐。他只是这个冷静的中心。他似乎在说真话。他有时很风趣。他有时听起来很痛苦。他很坦诚。但他似乎很理智，而其他所有人都显得有点精神失常。
So before we go to the break, let's get the claimant, who we've sometimes called Alton, and we've sometimes called him Roger Tichborne. But let's just call him the claimant. Let's get him to England. So they've got together in Sydney. I mean, this is such a complicated story that we're really only scratching the surface. I know. In Sydney, he makes some bad mistakes, doesn't he?
所以在我们休息之前，让我们把冒名顶替者带进来，我们有时叫他奥顿，有时叫他罗杰·蒂奇伯恩。但让我们就叫他冒名顶替者。让我们把他带到英国。所以他们在悉尼凑到了一起。我的意思是，这是一个如此复杂的故事，我们真的只是触及了表面。我知道。在悉尼，他犯了一些严重的错误，不是吗？
He gets his own mother's name wrong, which I think is a kind of giveaway, I think. And the whole lack of French. The lack of French. Yeah. And he doesn't speak French. And Roger, because his mother was French, had been raised speaking French, really as French. The lack of French. Yeah. And he doesn't speak French. And Roger, because his mother was French, had been raised speaking French, really as his first language. So one would think those two crucial details.
他弄错了自己母亲的名字，我认为这是一种泄密，我想。还有完全不懂法语。不懂法语。是的。而且他不会说法语。罗杰，因为他母亲是法国人，从小讲法语，真的像法国人一样。不懂法语。是的。而且他不会说法语。罗杰，因为他母亲是法国人，从小讲法语，真的把法语作为他的第一语言。所以人们会认为这两个关键细节。
You'd think. But he sails for England, doesn't he? And he manages not to sink the ship, despite his enormous weight. Yeah. Doesn't he go to Franceance i mean that's an amazing scene they go on the boat and some money has been sent to them so quite painfully i think he takes the good seat on the boat and paul bogle and his family are in you know third class with the rest in steerage and then they get to paris and even as they get there arthur is a bit nervous about
你会这么想。但他启航去英国了，不是吗？而且他设法没有让船沉没，尽管他体重惊人。是的。他不是去了法国吗？我的意思是，那是一个神奇的场景，他们上了船，一些钱被寄给了他们，所以相当痛苦地，我想他坐了船上的好座位，保罗·博格尔（Paul Bogle）和他的家人在，你知道，三等舱，和其他人在统舱里，然后他们到了巴黎，即使他们到了那里，亚瑟也有点紧张
it understandably it's a big lie. And this is the crunch point. So he, instead of going to the mother, hides in a hotel room with a handkerchief over his face and says, he's not feeling well. He's not feeling well. Loads of excuses. And then the mother finally says, well, I'm coming to you. And then he darkens the room. She walks in. He's like, oh, don't look at my face. I mean, it's so absurd. And he turns to the wall and she's like, no, Roger Darling, let me see your face. And his hand is trembling. And this is the moment.
关于它，可以理解，这是一个巨大的谎言。这是关键点。所以他没有去见母亲，而是躲在酒店房间里，用手帕捂着脸，说他感觉不舒服。他感觉不舒服。各种借口。然后母亲终于说，好吧，我来看你。然后他把房间弄暗了。她走了进来。他就像，哦，别看我的脸。我的意思是，这太荒谬了。他转向墙壁，她就像，不，罗杰亲爱的，让我看看你的脸。他的手在颤抖。这就是那一刻。
You take it off. There she is. You've got to England. It's come this far. You might think, well, I did my best. And that's the moment where she says, no, that's him. It's unbelievable. He must have been amazed himself that he got that far.
你把它拿下来。她就在那里。你到了英国。已经走到这一步了。你可能会想，好吧，我已经尽力了。那就是她说的时刻，不，那是他。这太不可思议了。他自己一定很惊讶他能走到那一步。
It's incredible. Unless he was, in fact that he got that far. Wow. It's incredible. Unless he was, in fact, Sir Roger Tichborne. Stop it. Well, so the case is deepening. I think we should take a break here. And when we come back, we will find out what happens to Sir Roger, a.k.a. Arthur Orton, a.k.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. A giant, the chin-strapped beard had receded many inches to make room for the several extra stone gained since last photographed, and every button strained at the sheer girth of the man.
这太不可思议了。除非他实际上，他能走到那一步。哇。这太不可思议了。除非他实际上，是罗杰·蒂奇伯恩爵士。别说了。好吧，所以案件正在加深。我想我们应该在这里休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将找出罗杰爵士，也就是亚瑟·奥顿，发生了什么。therestisentertainment.com。一个巨人，下巴上的胡须已经退后了几英寸，为自上次拍照以来增加的几英石体重腾出了空间，每一颗纽扣都因为这个男人巨大的腰围而紧绷。
So that is Zadie Smith's description of the claimant in her new novel, The Fraud, this colossally large man who claims to be Sir Roger Tichborne, who previously had been very sylph-like and has vanished in the ocean. And now the claimant is claiming to be him and has come where we left him. He was in Paris. He had just met his mother, or is she his mother? And Sadie, what happens next after Sir Roger's mother recognises this guy who claims to be her long lost son? Well, she gives him a thousand pounds a year. I mean, it's just incredible. What an achievement.
这就是扎迪·史密斯在她的小说《欺诈》中对冒名顶替者的描述，这个极其庞大的男人声称自己是罗杰·蒂奇伯恩爵士，他以前非常像个苗条的精灵，已经在海洋中消失了。现在冒名顶替者声称是他，并来到了我们离开他的地方。他在巴黎。他刚刚见了他的母亲，或者她是他的母亲吗？扎迪，在罗杰爵士的母亲认出这个声称是她失散多年儿子的家伙之后，接下来发生了什么？嗯，她给了他每年一千英镑。我的意思是，这简直不可思议。多么大的成就。
And then dies very inconveniently for Arthur Orton, stroke Sir Roger. She dies and suddenly he is without any support. Nobody else in the Tichborne family will claim him. And he is somehow emboldened. I mean, I would run away at that point, but he just doesn't. He decides to fight the case and basically sue the family.
然后非常不合时宜地为亚瑟·奥顿，也就是罗杰爵士去世了。她去世了，突然间他失去了任何支持。蒂奇伯恩家族中没有其他人会认领他。而他不知何故变得胆大起来。我的意思是，我会在那个时候逃跑，但他就是不。他决定打这场官司，基本上起诉这个家族。
That's extremely bold, right? Very. You're suing them to get the tenant out of your pretend house. Yeah. That's really amazing. I'll tell you a detail that I think is telling, actually. So I said, is he Sir Roger Tichepon? But I don't think he is.
这非常大胆，对吧？非常。你起诉他们是为了把租户从你假装的房子里赶出去。是的。这真的很神奇。我告诉你一个我认为很有说明性的细节，实际上。所以我说，他是罗杰·蒂奇伯恩爵士吗？但我不认为他是。
Big spoiler. Because when he first got to London, he had made a special trip to Wapham and inquired after the Orton family. Now, the Ortons are the Butchers. That's the Butcher's family. Now, if he was really Sir Roger Tichborne, there's no way he'd have gone and inquired after a Butcher's family. And this was brought up in court.
大剧透。因为当他第一次到达伦敦时，他专门去了一趟沃平，打听奥顿家族的情况。现在，奥顿家族是屠夫。那是屠夫的家族。现在，如果他真的是罗杰·蒂奇伯恩爵士，他绝不可能去打听一个屠夫的家族。这在法庭上被提出来了。
And his explanation was, you know what i met arthur orton in australia and he couldn't come and i just thought i should go and say to his family you know he's doing well he's fine yeah he's alive um that part of the testimony went on for literal months over and over again that story was repeated and during the trial he is secretly paying various of his Orton relatives to say that they don't recognize him and he's paying them to do that yeah right yeah he's secretly paying them and where's he getting his money from well that's the other thing the subscription fund the minute the money is taken away from him by the Tichbornes the The working people of England, mostly, who gathered in support of him, started a fund to support the case. So this is like the housemaid who marries?
他的解释是，你知道吗，我在澳大利亚遇到了亚瑟·奥顿，他不能来，我只是觉得我应该去告诉他的家人，你知道他过得很好，他很好，是的，他还活着，嗯，那部分的证词持续了几个月，一遍又一遍地重复那个故事，在审判期间，他秘密地付钱给他的各个奥顿亲戚，让他们说他们不认识他，他付钱让他们那样做，是的，对，是的，他秘密地付钱给他们，他从哪里弄来的钱？嗯，那是另一回事，认购基金，蒂奇伯恩家一拿走他的钱，英国的劳动人民，大多数人，聚集起来支持他，开始了一个基金来支持这个案件。所以这就像那个嫁给威廉·安斯沃思的女仆？
Who marries William Ainsworth. They were really obsessed with him. And that part of the case is what interested me most. Because though it all sounds crazy, in the context of the time, working people in these courts were getting screwed on a daily basis. That's fair to say, right? Like your working class son steals a sheep, might find himself sent to Australia, might find himself hung at Tyburn Tree. So this had been going on for a long time in a court, which was almost exclusively populated by upper middle class juries and aristocratic judges and lawyers. I think the masses in England saw this as an opportunity to say, let's have one of our own win for once. Though the logic of that, of course, is demented. Yes, because the bind is that if he is one of their own, then he can't be Sir Roger. Right. It doesn't make sense.
谁嫁给了威廉·安斯沃思。他们真的对他很着迷。案件的那一部分是我最感兴趣的。因为虽然这一切听起来很疯狂，但在当时的情况下，劳动人民在这些法庭上每天都被坑。这很公平，对吧？就像你的工人阶级儿子偷了一只羊，可能会发现自己被送到澳大利亚，可能会发现自己在泰伯恩树（Tyburn Tree）上被绞死。所以这在法庭上已经持续了很长时间，法庭几乎完全由中上层阶级的陪审团和贵族法官及律师组成。我认为英国的群众把这看作是一个机会，说，让我们赢一次吧。虽然这其中的逻辑当然是疯狂的。是的，因为困境在于，如果他是他们中的一员，那么他就不能是罗杰爵士。对。这说不通。
But if he is, then they're rallying to the cause of a kind of posh aristocrat. Right. The analogy in my mind, the first time I read it, is OJ. It's a similar situation where an obvious lie is being used to reveal a different kind of truth about the court system. But just one other thing that you bring up brilliantly in the novel is the way in which this does have the quality of some melodrama. I mean, it seems so implausible and extraordinary as to be fictional. So you have a great description of people coming to watch it as though they're going to the music hall. The people had come prepared. They had winkle pots and paper cones of chestnuts to accompany the entertainment
但如果他是，那么他们就是在为一个某种时髦的贵族事业而团结起来。对。我第一次读到它时，脑海中的类比是辛普森案（OJ）。这是一个类似的情况，一个明显的谎言被用来揭示关于法庭系统的另一种真相。但你还在小说中精彩地提出了另一件事，那就是它确实具有某种情节剧的特质。我的意思是，它看起来如此不可信和非凡，以至于像是虚构的。所以你对人们来看它就像去音乐厅一样有很好的描述。人们已经做好了准备。他们带着螺纹罐和纸筒栗子来陪伴娱乐，
and laughed and applauded the cross examinations exactly as if at the music hall. I think the line between court and theatre at that moment in British jurisprudence history is quite thin. Like when you're reading the court transcript, it's funny. Above all, it's funny. And what we would consider normal behaviour in a courtroom now doesn't exist. Like a summing up can literally take two and a half months. Yes. Well, talking of the courtroom, there's one character in particular so we alluded to him
并像在音乐厅一样对交叉询问大笑和鼓掌。我认为在英国司法史的那一刻，法庭和剧院之间的界限很薄。就像当你读法庭记录时，它很有趣。最重要的是，它很有趣。而我们现在认为法庭上的正常行为在当时并不存在。比如总结陈词真的可以持续两个半月。是的。嗯，说到法庭，有一个角色特别，所以我们提到了他
right at the beginning here's this bloke from court called edward canely is it canely yeah i mean he puts on one of the most extraordinary performances actually in the history of the british courts doesn't he so he is acting in the second case so there's been a first case which he loses yeah which goes on for know, 27 years or whatever. So in the second case, he is now the criminal, someone who is pretended to be somebody else. So it's kind of Oscar Wilde. Yeah, exactly. Oscar Wilde-esque.
就在开头，这里有一个来自法庭的家伙叫爱德华·卡内利，是卡内利吗？是的，我的意思是，他实际上在英国法庭历史上上演了最非凡的表演之一，不是吗？所以他在第二个案件中采取行动，所以有一个他输掉的第一个案件，是的，它持续了，你知道，27年或什么的。所以在第二个案件中，他现在是罪犯，一个假装成别人的人。所以这有点像奥斯卡·王尔德（Oscar Wilde）。是的，完全是。奥斯卡·王尔德式的。
Yeah. That the guy who brings the case then finds himself on trial. Right. It's the flip. And when the flip happens, Keneally is his defense lawyer. And again, it reveals something about English law at that time that previously in another life, Keneally was a poet lawyer. And again, it reveals something about the English law at that time that previously in another life, Keneally was a poet. He gave up poetry.
是的。那个提起诉讼的人最后发现自己反而成了被告。没错。这就是反转。当反转发生时，基尼利（Keneally）成了他的辩护律师。这再次揭示了当时英国法律的一些情况，那就是在之前的另一段人生中，基尼利曾是一位诗人律师。这再次揭示了当时英国法律的一些情况，那就是在之前的另一段人生中，基尼利曾是一位诗人。他放弃了诗歌。
He retrained as a lawyer. But training as a lawyer at that point is, as far as I can see, a very loose system. Because what he's basically doing in court is just telling very, very long stories. That's what we do. Yeah, just like a podcast or like a novelist without much rational bounds to them and unfortunately for ditchborn and everyone involved keneally was also i would say quite profoundly mentally ill he's bonkers yeah yeah i was reading up on him tom you'd love him he's got a great beard that kind of wg grace beard he wrote a pantomime in verse about girter
他改行做了律师。但据我所知，当时的律师培训体系非常松散。因为他在法庭上基本上只是在讲非常、非常长的故事。我们就是这么做的。是的，就像播客一样，或者像个没什么理性约束的小说家。不幸的是，对于蒂奇伯恩（Tichborne）和所有相关人员来说，基尼利本人我也得说，精神上相当严重地出了问题，他是个疯子。是的，是的，我读过关于他的资料，汤姆，你会喜欢他的。他留着很棒的胡子，那种WG·格雷斯（WG Grace）式的胡子。他甚至写过一部关于格尔特（Girter）的韵文哑剧。
yeah just for starters and then he wrote a book called the book of god in which he said he was the oh yes i love this he was the 12th messenger of god descended get this from two very dissimilar people jesus and genghis khan yeah wow i think we're all descended from genghis khan to be fair. Yeah. Are we? I think that's what genetics proves, I think. That's one of those Twitter facts that I find very implausible, ultimately. No, Adam Rutherford is always telling me this, and I don't understand it, but apparently it is true. Keneally believed that, and he also had kind of like Steve Bannon-like theories of history,
是的，这只是个开始。然后他写了一本书叫《上帝之书》（The Book of God），在书中他说他是……哦，是的，我喜欢这个，他是上帝的第12位使者，是——听好了——两个截然不同的人的后代：耶稣和成吉思汗。是的，哇。公平地说，我想我们都是成吉思汗的后代。是吗？我想遗传学证明了这一点，我想是这样。那是那种我觉得最终非常不可信的推特事实之一。不，亚当·卢瑟福（Adam Rutherford）总是跟我说这个，我不明白，但显然这是真的。基尼利相信这一点，而且他还有一些类似史蒂夫·班农（Steve Bannon）的历史理论，
of centuries turning in a certain direction, all to the apex of him. He was basically the resolution of history. Brilliant. We're just waiting for the arrival of Keneally. And this is the man who was the lawyer on the case. And is that because, as it were, real lawyers? Almost all lawyers said, no, thank you. Yeah, right.
认为几个世纪都在朝着某个方向发展，而这一切的顶点就是他自己。他基本上就是历史的终结。太精彩了。我们只是在等待基尼利的到来。而这就是那个案件的辩护律师。这是因为，所谓的真正的律师们，几乎所有的律师都说，不，谢谢。是的，没错。
Yeah. He was one of the last people who would accept it. And while running the case was also kind of building a political movement around the case. He began this thing called the Magna Charta Association, which took up a series of kind of political positions, including kind of anti-vaxxing positions, fascinatingly. Because I found that amazing. Yeah, it is amazing. This is what the Tichborne Gazette, they're putting out, aren't they? And it's kind of focused around making the case that he is Sir Roger.
是的。他是最后几个愿意接手的人之一。而且在处理案件的同时，他还在围绕这个案件建立一场政治运动。他发起了所谓的“大宪章协会”（Magna Charta Association），该协会采取了一系列政治立场，令人着迷的是，其中甚至包括反疫苗立场。因为我觉得这太不可思议了。是的，这确实令人惊叹。这就是《蒂奇伯恩公报》（Tichborne Gazette）所发布的内容，对吧？它主要集中在证明他就是罗杰爵士（Sir Roger）这一点上。
But it has supplementary causes, yeah. Yeah, for who knew the true intentions of these rich men and their needles. Yeah, so their favourite things were, let's make Tichborne win this case. It was anti-Catholic. There was a big anti-Catholic strain in it. Anti-vax. Somewhat chartist. Its best parts were kind of an enormous coalition of people wanting more right
但它还有补充性的事业，是的。是的，谁知道这些富人和他们的针（needles）的真实意图呢。是的，所以他们最喜欢的事情是，让我们让蒂奇伯恩赢得这场官司。它是反天主教的。其中有一种强烈的反天主教倾向。反疫苗。某种程度上是宪章派的。它最好的部分是某种由想要更多权利的人组成的庞大联盟，
for the working man. But inside it were all these kind of extreme fringe elements. And Keneally was running it, you know, outside of the courtroom. So how much does this case, before we get back to the second trial, just on all that, the newspapers, the kind of people raising money, I mean, just listening to you talking about it, it's impossible not to think of all the conspiracy stuff that flourishes today, driven by a new kind of media, by social media. How much is this basically, I mean, I know it's sort of trite comparison actually, but I've started, so I'll continue. Go on, go for it, Dominic. In for a penny, in for a pound, like the butcher. Going hard. I love a trite comparison. How much is this effectively a Victorian equivalent of the
为工人阶级争取权利。但内部却充斥着各种极端的边缘分子。基尼利在法庭外运作着这一切。那么，在我们回到第二次审判之前，就所有这些报纸、筹款的人来说，听你谈论这些，让人不禁想到今天在社交媒体等新媒体驱动下蓬勃发展的各种阴谋论。这在多大程度上基本上是——我知道这其实是个陈词滥调的比较，但我已经开始了，所以我会继续说下去。继续，说吧，多米尼克。既然开始了，就得做到底，就像那个屠夫一样。全力以赴。我喜欢陈词滥调的比较。这在多大程度上实际上是维多利亚时代的
kind of ferment of mad theories and paranoias about rich elites and all that stuff that we have now? And driven by new newspapers and stuff like that. Yeah. I mean, I started it before Trump and all of that, but the analogies are impossible to avoid. And I think it's just because they're both studies in populism. And I think I got very used to the critique of right wing populism, but this is something different. This really is left wing populism. It's quite irrational. It's class based, but also fascinatingly to me, it did work. So one of the complaints of the people was that these courts were prejudiced against them, particularly the juries. And in the second trial, under this enormous public pressure and rhetoric which was passing around about the class-based system in the courts, the jury was then deliberately filled with only working people. And I think that might be one of the first times that happened in England. So it's an interesting case of what seems to be a deeply irrational, almost crazy case working its way through a court and transforming it in some small way.
那种关于富人精英的疯狂理论和偏执狂的温床，就像我们现在所拥有的一样？而且是由新报纸之类的东西驱动的。是的。我的意思是，我在特朗普和所有这一切之前就开始了，但这些类比是无法避免的。我认为这只是因为它们都是民粹主义的研究。我非常习惯于对右翼民粹主义的批判，但这有些不同。这确实是左翼民粹主义。它相当不理性。它是基于阶级的，但同样令我着迷的是，它确实奏效了。所以人们的抱怨之一是这些法院对他们有偏见，特别是陪审团。在第二次审判中，在巨大的公众压力和关于法院阶级制度的言论下，陪审团被特意填满了工人阶级。我想这可能是英国第一次发生这种情况。所以这是一个有趣的案例，一个看起来极其不理性、近乎疯狂的案件在法庭中运作，并以某种微小的方式改变了它。
So I don't know, maybe it's an example of how populism, as frightening as it sometimes can be, does also function in some way and is a weird machine for manipulating people's emotions to some political end. And to what extent do you think this kind of vast populist enthusiasm for the claimant is making fantastical figures out of both the claimant and Andrew Bogle, who is the chief substantiating witness? Because you give a kind of brilliant backstory of Andrew Bogle, of his father who is taken from Africa and experience of the plantations before the
所以我不知道，也许这是一个例子，说明民粹主义，尽管有时令人恐惧，但也确实以某种方式发挥作用，并且是一种将人们的情绪操纵到某种政治目的的奇怪机器。你认为这种对原告的巨大民粹主义热情在多大程度上将原告和安德鲁·博格尔（Andrew Bogle，主要证实证人）塑造成了虚构的人物？因为你给安德鲁·博格尔提供了一个精彩的背景故事，关于他父亲如何从非洲被带走，以及在废除奴隶制之前在种植园的经历。
abolition of slavery. How much of that is based on fact? I mean, that's all fact. I mean, everything that happens in the plantation scenes happens on those plantations. And one of the amazing things about writing this book is that UCL have digitized every plantation in Jamaica. So you can get very granular, every name, every job, every child. So we know exactly which plantation he was born on. Yeah, yeah, exactly. He was on Hope and we have all the details. So I had all the facts, which was an incredible thing.
其中有多少是基于事实的？我的意思是，那全是事实。我的意思是，种植园场景中发生的一切都发生在那些种植园里。写这本书最令人惊奇的事情之一是，伦敦大学学院（UCL）已经将牙买加的每一个种植园数字化了。所以你可以得到非常细致的信息，每一个名字、每一份工作、每一个孩子。所以我们确切地知道他出生在哪个种植园。是的，是的，完全正确。他在“希望”（Hope）种植园，我们有所有的细节。所以我掌握了所有的事实，这是一件不可思议的事情。
But I think what interested me and interested Borges is these Victorian lives that passed through so many situations. How extraordinary to be born in that situation and then come to London and find yourself in the High Court. It was so hard to imagine what kind of a life was that, where you were in so many different worlds simultaneously. But he did become a legend. And those meetings that Tichborne or Arthur held all around the country, they were held in the same places where, you know, for example, Dickens spoke, where political rallies were held. They look like Trump rallies. Like you turn up in town, hundreds and hundreds of people come. There are banners. There are people screaming and shouting. And there's a lot of paraphernalia. Hundreds and hundreds of people come. There are banners. There are people screaming and shouting.
但我认为让我和博格斯（Borges）感兴趣的是这些经历了如此多境遇的维多利亚时代的生活。出生在那样的环境中，然后来到伦敦，发现自己身处高等法院，这是多么非凡啊。很难想象那是一种什么样的生活，你同时身处这么多不同的世界。但他确实成为了一个传奇。蒂奇伯恩或亚瑟（Arthur）在全国各地举行的那些会议，它们举行的地点和狄更斯（Dickens）演讲的地方、举行政治集会的地方是一样的。它们看起来就像特朗普的集会。就像你来到镇上，成百上千的人来了。有横幅。有人尖叫和呐喊。还有很多随身物品。成百上千的人来了。有横幅。有人尖叫和呐喊。
And there's a lot of paraphernalia. Like if you go to junk stores now, you can still find little models of Bogle and Tichborne, plates, cups. Yeah, it's extraordinary to me that it was that popular and then so completely forgotten. That's the other thing. And also they are fabricating witnesses, aren't they? So they come up with a Dane called Jean-Louis, who claims to have been a steward on the ship that had rescued Sir Roger from drowning and then taken him to Melbourne. He's a paid actor. Yeah, a false flag, as they would say these days.
还有很多随身物品。就像如果你现在去旧货店，你仍然可以找到博格尔和蒂奇伯恩的小模型、盘子、杯子。是的，它曾经那么受欢迎，然后又被完全遗忘，这对我来说太不可思议了。这是另一回事。而且他们还在伪造证人，不是吗？所以他们找来一个叫让-路易（Jean-Louis）的丹麦人，他声称自己是救起罗杰爵士并带他去墨尔本的船上的管家。他是个付费演员。是的，就像他们现在所说的“假旗行动”（false flag）。
A recently released convict. Yeah, you're watching a court system in which it's perfectly normal to say, we're going to have 210 witnesses. So it wasn't a practical system. And I think part of the effect of this trial was that the English legal system looked at itself and said, this can't continue. You can't call 250 witnesses. And this post states, jarndice and jarndice,
一个刚出狱的罪犯。是的，你正在观察一个法律体系，在这个体系中，说“我们要传唤210名证人”是完全正常的。所以这不是一个实用的系统。我认为这次审判的部分影响是，英国法律体系审视了自己并说，这不能再继续下去了。你不能传唤250名证人。这发生在《荒凉山庄》（Bleak House）之后，
as Dickens already written Bleak House at this point. One of the questions was, did Dickens go to this trial? But then, of course, I realized he's dead just before it. He missed the trial that he would have adored.ored yeah so Bleak House is 20 years before this actually yeah no it's a perfectly Dickensian trial but he is dead before it but Elliot is there George Elliot went to see it I don't know what she made of it but I love the idea of her sitting there watching this it's much more Dickens than George Elliot isn't it the whole shenanigans yeah it's not to her taste at all she doesn't like this amount of irrationality and poor behaviour.
狄更斯当时已经写了《荒凉山庄》了吗？其中一个问题是，狄更斯去参加这次审判了吗？但后来我意识到他在审判前就去世了。他错过了他本会喜欢的审判。是的，所以《荒凉山庄》实际上是在这之前20年。是的，不，这是一场完美的狄更斯式的审判，但他确实在审判前就去世了。但艾略特（Elliot）在那里，乔治·艾略特（George Elliot）去看了。我不知道她对此有何感想，但我喜欢她坐在那里观看这一切的想法。这比乔治·艾略特更像狄更斯，不是吗？整个闹剧。是的，这根本不合她的口味，她不喜欢这种程度的不理性和糟糕的行为。
Very poor behaviour. We've had a lot of poor behaviour in the rest of history, but we've never had poor behaviour like this. So, this is actually the longest trial in English history, I think, isn't it? I think MacLibel takes it, actually, in the 90s. Okay, but until...
非常糟糕的行为。我们在历史的其他部分经历过很多糟糕的行为，但我们从未经历过这样的糟糕行为。所以，这实际上是英国历史上最长的审判，我想，不是吗？我想麦当劳诽谤案（MacLibel）实际上在90年代超过了它。好吧，但在……
Until then, yeah, it's the longest. But it actually ends so quickly. okay but until until then yeah it's the longest but it actually ends so quickly so there's a bit issue of tattoos isn't there yes of course there is there's not the moment that basically this case falls apart because there's a bloke who was at boarding school with him we always love a boarding school story tom stonyhurst is it stonyhurst a jesuit boarding school i mean who would go to a jesuit boarding school bonkers anyway that's by the by he's gone to this school and a bloke pitches up who says i was at school with him and he had some very distinctive tattoos right seems odd that a teenager would have loads of tattoos but well who knows they did it to each other maybe just inked each other inked each other yeah inked each other that sounds odd but you know what i mean like yeah probably your friends did it
在那之前，是的，它是最长的。但它实际上结束得很快。好吧，但在那之前，是的，它是最长的，但它实际上结束得很快。所以有一个关于纹身的问题，不是吗？是的，当然有。那一刻基本上是这个案件崩溃的原因，因为有一个和他一起上寄宿学校的家伙——我们总是喜欢寄宿学校的故事，汤姆——是斯托尼赫斯特（Stonyhurst）吗？一所耶稣会寄宿学校。我的意思是，谁会去耶稣会寄宿学校？疯了。总之，那是题外话。他去了这所学校，一个家伙跑过来说，我和他一起上学，他有一些非常独特的纹身。对，一个十几岁的孩子身上有那么多纹身似乎很奇怪，但谁知道呢，他们可能互相纹的，也许只是互相刺青。互相刺青。是的，互相刺青。这听起来很奇怪，但你知道我的意思，就像，是的，可能是你的朋友干的。
but that's what did for him yeah i think it's a bit like trump and stormy daniels it's not the thing you yeah i think is going to take you down it's always some al capone and the tax return yeah it's always some small thing and in the end not having a tattoo on his arm is the killer was the end of it yeah because the jury say to the judge we've heard enough we don't need the other 3 000 witnesses yeah that's it yeah two and a half years we're good it was a tattoo and that was it and suddenly he was imprisoned for 14 years i think and by the time he was released he was like a broken man he then did confess to being arthur orton to a newspaper to get some money.
但这就是让他完蛋的原因。是的，我想这有点像特朗普和斯托米·丹尼尔斯（Stormy Daniels），这不是你认为会让你倒台的事情。总是像阿尔·卡彭（Al Capone）和纳税申报表一样。总是些小事。最后，手臂上没有纹身是致命的，是终结。是的，因为陪审团对法官说，我们听够了，我们不需要另外3000名证人了。是的，就是这样。两年半，我们受够了。就是一个纹身，就是这样。突然间他被判入狱14年，我想。当他获释时，他已经是一个破碎的人了。他后来向一家报纸承认自己是亚瑟·奥顿（Arthur Orton）以换取一些钱。
And with that money, set up a cigarette shop in Islington. But years later, right? Years later. And paid by a newspaper. But then he retracts it, doesn't he? And then he retracted it again, still playing the game, and then died broke, destitute. And then, to bring the story full circle, was buried right next to my house which is how i
用那些钱，在伊斯灵顿（Islington）开了一家香烟店。但那是几年后，对吧？几年后。而且是由报纸支付的。但后来他撤回了，不是吗？然后他又撤回了，还在玩这个游戏，最后死的时候身无分文，一贫如洗。然后，为了让故事圆满，他被埋在我家旁边，这就是我
came to know about all of this in the first place in paddington cemetery off wilsdon lane is that so yeah but buried as who well this is the thing so when it was announced he was going to be buried and the case had been you know it was a long time since this had happened and you think most people have forgotten about it but suddenly everybody was interested again. And there's a photograph you can see online of 5,000 people in Wilsdon Lane. Wow. 5,000 came to see him buried. And the Tichborne family, for some reason, though they'd fought him all those years, said, fair play. You can have a little cardboard thing on top of the coffin saying Sir Roger Tichborne.
最初知道这一切的原因，在威尔斯登巷（Wilsdon Lane）附近的帕丁顿公墓（Paddington Cemetery）。是这样吗？是的，但他是以谁的名义下葬的？嗯，这就是问题所在。所以当宣布他要下葬时，距离这件事发生已经过去很长时间了，你以为大多数人都已经忘记了，但突然间每个人又都感兴趣了。你可以在网上看到一张照片，威尔斯登巷有5000人。哇。5000人来看他下葬。而蒂奇伯恩家族，出于某种原因，尽管他们多年来一直与他抗争，却说，公平竞争。你可以在棺材上放一个小纸板，上面写着“罗杰·蒂奇伯恩爵士”。
That's nice of them. That's so bizarre, isn't it? It's so bizarre. And he was buried in a pauper's grave. Yeah. There was no money to bury him. And there's no stone. So it wasn't that official.
他们真好。这太离奇了，不是吗？太离奇了。他被埋在贫民墓里。是的。没有钱埋葬他。而且没有墓碑。所以那并不正式。
But apparently they let this little cardboard sign. Why did they do that? That's mad. I don't know. It's sentimental or Dominic or... Guilt. Were they admitting? Yeah, guilt.
但显然他们允许放那个小纸板标志。他们为什么要那样做？太疯狂了。我不知道。是多愁善感，多米尼克，还是……内疚。他们是在承认吗？是的，内疚。
Yeah. So there he lies. And I walk past him every day with the dog in this pauper's grave yeah and what happens to andrew bogle borges said he was run over in king's cross but that's a romance it's not true he just died poor in king's cross also a pauper's grave his mixed-race son had had by that point 11 children so i always assume there are a lot of bogles in England. They're probably white or they might be any other colour. I guess they might have married whoever, but they might not know that they are related to this extraordinary man.
是的。所以他就躺在那里。我每天带着狗经过这个贫民墓。是的，安德鲁·博格尔怎么样了？博格斯说他在国王十字车站（King's Cross）被车撞了，但那是个浪漫的说法，不是真的。他只是在国王十字车站贫困地死去，也是一个贫民墓。他的混血儿子当时已经有了11个孩子，所以我总是假设英国有很多博格尔的后代。他们可能是白人，也可能是其他任何肤色。我猜他们可能和任何人结婚了，但他们可能不知道自己与这个非凡的人有亲缘关系。
And what about Tichbornes? The Tichbornes continue, I think. There's a few Tichborne pubs in Hampshire, which I still haven't visited, which I'm excited by. The house I I know, doesn't belong to them anymore because I saw it in the Sunday Times for sale one day. Not for very much money even. Oh, go for it. No, I don't think it has much land left. I think it's just the house now. There must be Tichbornes around, but I don't think their wealth continued. And I don't know if they still get the rents from Doughty Street. The Baronetcy is expired. I'm looking at it here. 1968. Yes, that's it. There you go. Sir Anthony Doughty Tichborne.
那蒂奇伯恩家族呢？蒂奇伯恩家族还在，我想。汉普郡有几家蒂奇伯恩酒吧，我还没去过，我很兴奋。我知道的那栋房子，不再属于他们了，因为有一天我在《星期日泰晤士报》上看到它在出售。甚至没卖多少钱。哦，去吧。不，我不认为它还剩下多少土地。我想现在只剩下房子了。周围一定还有蒂奇伯恩家族的人，但我不认为他们的财富延续了下来。我不知道他们是否还在从道蒂街（Doughty Street）收取租金。准男爵爵位已经过期了。我在这里看着呢。1968年。是的，就是这样。你看。安东尼·道蒂·蒂奇伯恩爵士（Sir Anthony Doughty Tichborne）。
And so the one last legacy of this case is our word titchy. Yeah, that part is crazy. And for the relief of my readers, I did not add another 58 pages on this topic. I restrained myself, which I thought was good. But there was a musical figure who apparently looked a bit like Arthur Orton in the face and was quite round but with the key difference of being four foot six which is really quite small and he was called Little Titch and was a massive music hall star performed in blackface a lot of the time which is fascinating but his most famous routine was with these two massive ski feet.
所以这个案件留下的最后一个遗产就是我们的词“titchy”（微小的）。是的，那部分太疯狂了。为了读者的解脱，我没有在这个话题上再加58页。我克制住了自己，我觉得这很好。但有一个音乐人物，脸长得有点像亚瑟·奥顿，而且很圆，但关键区别是他只有四英尺六英寸高，这真的很小，他叫“小蒂奇”（Little Titch），是一位非常著名的音乐厅明星，经常表演黑脸秀，这很迷人，但他最著名的节目是穿着那双巨大的滑雪板鞋。
He was called Big Boots, and he would do a big boot dance in which, you know that bit in Smooth Criminal where Michael Jackson goes all the way to the floor almost and back again? Little Titch did that first. On the skis, he would go all the way to the floor and back. There's a video of it you can see online, and he was an incredible hit. So we still say things are Titchy because of Little Titch. Yeah, I had a friend at school when I was eight.
他被称为“大靴子”（Big Boots），他会跳大靴子舞，你知道迈克尔·杰克逊（Michael Jackson）在《Smooth Criminal》里几乎贴地又回来的那一段吗？小蒂奇先做到了。穿着滑雪板鞋，他会一直贴到地板再回来。网上有视频可以看到，他当时非常轰动。所以我们仍然因为“小蒂奇”而说东西是“titchy”。是的，我八岁时在学校有个朋友。
I mean, he was just called Titch. Everyone called him Titch. Yeah. And it never occurred to me. Yeah, or where that word came from. That he was called Little Titch after the Titchborn claimant. Yeah. Kind of perfect that this very musical trial ends up in the musical.
我的意思是，他就是叫“蒂奇”。每个人都叫他“蒂奇”。是的。我从来没想过。是的，或者那个词是从哪里来的。他叫“小蒂奇”是因为蒂奇伯恩原告。是的。这个非常音乐性的审判最终以音乐剧结束，这真是太完美了。
Yeah. Still with all the same themes around it. The idea of, you know of this black-faced character who's channeling some unseen place that nobody visits and nobody knows about. All the themes just keep on circling. Centre of England, the things on the border, and these strange, irrational actors.
是的。仍然围绕着同样的主题。那种……你知道，这个黑脸角色正在引导某个无人访问、无人知晓的隐秘地方的想法。所有的主题都在不断循环。英格兰的中心，边界上的事物，以及这些奇怪、不理性的参与者。
Yeah, it's fascinating. Just a question before we go, Zadie, about your book, The Fraud. Yes. So obviously, we've done however many episodes about history. We sometimes talk about historical fiction. So we talk about Patrick O'Brien or whoever it might be. But for you as a novelist writing about a period of history, do you feel a kind of obligation to the, you know,
是的，太迷人了。在离开之前问个问题，扎迪（Zadie），关于你的书《欺诈》（The Fraud）。是的。显然，我们已经做了很多关于历史的剧集。我们有时会谈论历史小说。所以我们谈论帕特里克·奥布莱恩（Patrick O'Brian）或其他任何人。但作为一名书写历史时期的小说家，你是否感到一种义务，你知道，
this is such a detailed story. There are, as it were, so many facts. Do you feel an obligation, a responsibility to keep to the facts? Or do you feel as a novelist, you have free reign as it were so many facts do you feel an obligation a responsibility to keep to the facts or do you feel as a novelist you have free reign as it were i remember hearing hillary talk about this mantel and i think she's right if you want to work with history you want to work with history the facts are important they're very important to me so i wouldn't see the point of manipulating them beyond reason. And in this case, you barely had to fictionalize. It is a fiction in itself. And I didn't change anything,
这是一个如此详细的故事。有这么多事实。你是否感到一种义务、一种责任去坚持事实？还是你觉得作为一名小说家，你有自由发挥的空间？有这么多事实，你是否感到一种义务、一种责任去坚持事实？还是你觉得作为一名小说家，你有自由发挥的空间？我记得听希拉里·曼特尔（Hillary Mantel）谈论过这个，我想她是正确的，如果你想处理历史，你想处理历史，事实很重要，它们对我来说非常重要。所以我看不出有任何理由去无理地操纵它们。在这种情况下，你几乎不需要虚构。它本身就是一种虚构。我什么都没改，
really. The only change is a fictional character outside of the case called Mrs. Touché, who is kind of extended beyond her normal lifespan or realm. But no, to me, the facts are really important. It's like a rearrangement of the facts into fiction, but not an obscuring or changing of them. It's the truth that fascinates me. But it's also a novel about Victorian novels to a degree, isn't it? Yeah. And I think I was just kind of interested in everything that Victorian novels hide or obscure. It's so common in a Victorian novel for the most useless son of the family to disappear to Jamaica or to Australia. And it's always out of sight. You never quite know where these useless
真的。唯一的改变是一个案件之外的虚构人物，叫图谢夫人（Mrs. Touché），她被延伸到了她正常的寿命或领域之外。但不，对我来说，事实真的很重要。这就像是将事实重新排列成小说，而不是掩盖或改变它们。是真相让我着迷。但这在某种程度上也是一部关于维多利亚时代小说的小说，不是吗？是的。我想我只是对维多利亚时代小说所隐藏或掩盖的一切感兴趣。在维多利亚时代的小说中，家里最没用的儿子消失在牙买加或澳大利亚是非常普遍的。而且总是看不见。你永远不知道这些没用的
sons are going to. So it was an opportunity for me to kind of know myself, to fill in those gaps and write it in full. But the energy of those Victorian novels and the incredible kind of imaginative engine of them is something I've envied all my life. There's such incredible generators of story. Well, you have done them proud. Wonderful. So Zadie Smith, thanks so much. Thanks so much.
儿子去了哪里。所以这对我来说是一个机会，可以去了解，去填补这些空白并完整地写出来。但那些维多利亚时代小说的能量和它们令人难以置信的想象力引擎是我一生都羡慕的。它们是如此不可思议的故事生成器。好吧，你让它们感到骄傲了。太棒了。那么扎迪·史密斯，非常感谢。非常感谢。
I loved it. The novel, The Fraud is absolutely unmissable. We hope you have enjoyed this extraordinary story. And who knows, the claimant, real or not, you decide. Thanks very much for listening. Bye-bye. Bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde.
我喜欢它。《欺诈》这部小说绝对不容错过。我们希望你喜欢这个非凡的故事。谁知道呢，原告是真是假，由你决定。非常感谢收听。再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。